esta es radio canadá internacional
bienvenidos a canadá en las américas
café en este domingo 19 de febrero de
2017 este es una emisión producida por
la sección en español de relanzamiento
ya asignar fe en comunidad puntos
diferentes
17 puntos o sea también es transmitida
en directo cada jueves a través de la
red social facebook
hoy les acompañan en los micrófonos de
honor a chapman pablo gómez barrios y
hoy tenemos como invitados a juan carlos
quintana iván gonzález yang y tenga un
rey y baby rodríguez si ellos van a
decirnos dentro de poco qué es lo que
hacen y que los trae los tres estudios y
también está como siempre leonardo
gimeno
en los controles de facebook allí entre
todos estamos la bienvenida
y entonces empezamos este programa
justamente con nuestros invitados juan
carlos quintana que los trae por aquí
pues rufo muchas gracias por recibirnos
a todo el equipo leonora pablo gusto
verte también leonardo el evento número
4 nos trae aquí el rojo que estamos
celebrando a la cuarta edición de este
evento que le permite a los latinos
latinos y los quebequenses de crear
lazos profesionales aquí en mostrar
habituarse el presidente de una
organización que se llama ajenos el
magazine y cuál es el propósito de esta
entidad mira en realidad agenda social
madre haciendo un comenzó hace cuatro
años con el objetivo de
los hispanos pudieran integrarse mejor
en este país y regalos latinos
creo que hispanos porque yo siempre lo
he hecho hispanos la verdad creo que es
importante no ser exclusiones al
contrario creo que la unión hace la
fuerza y por qué decir los latinos sino
hispanohablantes finalmente las revistas
es escrita en español entonces cualquier
personal que hable español o que está
aprendiendo español puede leerla y
cuando como te decía somos somos una
revista que lo que busca es integrar a
estos latinos aquí en el país por medio
de la cultura el deporte las actividades
y todo lo que lo que ofrece de montreal
y tenemos la visita de dos francos
mexicanos salimos e iván gonzález y van
que es que es el organismo que tú
representas
nosotros representamos a la asociación
estudiantil de magill que se llama es la
ssa es la asociación de estudiantes
hispanoparlantes
y lo que representamos en esta
asociación es básicamente promover la
cultura latina la cultura hispana al
igual que el idioma de español en la
comunidad joven y estudiantil no sólo de
majin pero también de la área de
material y sonido
y bueno pues ya llevamos es un club que
llevaba 20 años existiendo y hemos
creado lazos muy fuertes con otros
grupos estudiantiles como en concordia o
el niño esté de mujer
y otros grupos de latinos lo que es
interesante en vuestro caso es que ambos
tienen uno de los padres apa del padre o
la madre francés del franck francés
que es lo que les jalan a lo latino y no
a lo francés
bueno primero que nada pues crecimos en
la ciudad de méxico y aunque fuimos a un
liceo francés siempre nos sentimos muy
cercanos a la cultura mexicana y pues
fue ahí donde nos desarrollamos entonces
en que el lado francés lo tienen en
quebec y ahora si no hubieran ido a
toronto
no claro pero es una cosa para responder
a tu pregunta yo creo que como dijo yo
ahí va habiendo crecido la mayor parte
de nuestras vidas en méxico siempre
tuvimos esa atracción hacia el lado
latino hacia la calidez humana latina
que la mayoría de las culturas europeas
no tienen y que hacen el día de la
celebración de la batalla de puebla
hay dos que son compuso siempre nosotros
es el 5 de mayo y cuando méxico y
francia juegan fútbol
[Música]
son esos eventos que nos han ayudado a
definirnos
aquí en juan carlos habló de el evento
es un evento que se viene es esta es su
cuarta edición se va a llevar a cabo
pronto aquí en montreal recuerdo la
primera vez baby que hicimos una
entrevista que hablamos el primer evento
que se lanzaba hace ya tres años y
también de donde vos habías manifestado
su deseo de que era el primer evento
pero de que realmente se expande que se
convirtiera en algo sólido estuve
mirando un poco los vídeos de los tres
años que hicieron ustedes y encontré
gente que asistieron al evento que son
gente muy conocida de la comunidad
latinoamericana
la comunidad quebequense gente que
nosotros mismos entrevistamos aquí y lo
que sobresalían de sus tres vídeos
cuando escuché lo que la gente decía era
bueno que estaban porque están ahí en
ese evento era porque queremos
relacionarnos más con lo con los
quebequenses entrar más en contacto y
también queremos aprovechar y poner en
contacto redes de negocios que a veces
un negocio latino o incluso quebequense
andan perdidos por ahí entonces nosotros
tal vez podemos hacer un poco de unir
esas redes ya al tercer evento que es el
que se realizó cuál es el balance que
haces voces desde lo que se viene
realizando hasta ahora y en qué medida
esos objetivos se van realizando mirando
cuando sacamos el primer evento como te
lesiones en ese momento la entrevista
queríamos que se volviera algo
repetitivos queríamos que se volviera a
un movimiento de latinos aquí en quebec
que quisieran cambiar un poco la imagen
que tiene en su momento los latinos y
gracias a dios se nos dio la oportunidad
de hacerlo de cumplir con
nos hemos puesto de dar un producto
finalmente el cual estábamos en el que
queríamos llegar a tener con el evento
como te dices hay muchas personas de
gran nombre que han pasado en los
diferentes eventos y todos han tenido un
buen comentario siempre ha sido positivo
entonces para nosotros es verdaderamente
un orgullo es verdad / un placer poder
seguirlo haciendo seguiremos haciéndolo
a cada tres meses ya este año nos hemos
dado la misión de hacerlo trimestral así
que nada un año un año se pasó volando y
un año que gracias a ellos pues nos nos
brindó 43 ediciones que cuál es la
imagen en la que tú te refieres que
quieres cambiar y quiénes manejan esa
imagen mira hoy en día cuando tú le
dices a alguien latino lo primero que te
va a decir a baila salsa a las fiestas a
son muy alegres pero creo que somos más
que eso los latinos no somos solo eso no
digo que no lo somos porque al contrario
somos muy muy contentos nos encanta
hablar de fútbol hablar de fiestas somos
pero no somos solo eso somos tan gente
profesional somos gente que es luchadora
y que a veces creo que el prototipo al
que nos dicen latidos no está
relacionado a estas palabras entonces lo
que queremos es cambiar la imagen
demostrando que hay gente importante hay
gente en la política hay gente
hay gente empresarial estudiantes son el
futuro también que están preparando para
hacer una voz más importante en este
país justamente quienes manejan esa
imagen quienes la ponen en circulación
esa imagen que tú quieres que enviar
creo que son los líderes sinceramente
son los líderes y somos todos
desde la persona que es carnicero hasta
un saúl polo que es político creo que
todos somos importantes todos tenemos
que dar nuestro granito de arena y
demostrar que somos más que lo que los
que creen pero también para hacerle con
lo que está diciendo en los medios sabes
hay más y más latinos en los medios de
comunicación y siempre se relaciona al
latino con ricky martin la fiesta los
vídeos el reggaeton o sea que esa imagen
también sigue siendo vehicular y es
nuestra responsabilidad como latinos
aquí en canadá o en eeuu incluso de
seguir luchando para balancear eso que
dice baby que si somos alegres cuando
hay fiesta y fiesta cuando hay fútbol
hay food pero igual cuando se trata de
trabajar nos reconocen de ser
trabajadores
yo me pregunto si esa imagen que esos
ese estereotipo que está recibiendo este
pub y no somos nosotros mismos a veces
lo que lo difundimos por eso me gustaría
saber si a la gente que nos está
escuchando
en facebook en américa latina que nos
digan si es verdad que esta imagen del
latinoamericano que le gusta la pachanga
y que es flojo si realmente la tienen
ustedes allá o coinciden con la mesa
aquí de qué es eso pero también es mucho
más que eso lo justamente de ser
respecto a leonora tengo un comentario
aquí que nos viene desde argentina de
nuestro buen amigo daniel camporini y
camporini dice y saludos desde monde
desde mundo hispano me suena a español
no tengo nada contra españa pero soy
argentino y americano ustedes que dicen
de eso
depende de a qué escala quieres ver
y hay algo que nos junta a todos que es
la lengua y exclusivamente va más allá
ves desde las respectivas culturas
dentro de cada país aparte tienes
diferentes culturas entonces pero la
lengua nos une a todos y es una manera
el hecho de estar aquí fuera de la
américa latina que hace que uno para
ustedes sea más importante decir hispano
que el latinoamericano también se dice
hispano en méxico me imagino que dicen
guatemala
latino disculpen norteamericano porque
los hispanos en eeuu hay más hispanos en
eeuu que muchos países en américa tiene
incluso no pero sí para darle razón a lo
que están diciendo los compañeros
desplazan es y también hay lo que decía
es de incluirnos a todos porque si los
argentinos son pocos aquí básicamente
cuando nos comparamos al mercado
estadounidense somos pocos latinos aquí
si llegamos al millón y medio en todo
canadá es mucho menciones mucho rey
entonces hispanos porque nos incluimos
todos y trabajamos todos juntos hacia la
misma causa y al incluir hispanos y
incluimos a españa
mucha gente sale a bailar el 12 de
octubre diciendo que esto y el otro ya
son 500 años pero adónde vamos avancemos
juntos y eso es lo que nos hace hispanos
y todos trabajamos ahora el cuarto
evento lo que se va a llevar a cabo en
la universidad mcgill exactamente cómo
fue que se conectaron ustedes con
rodríguez y el evento fíjate eso sucedió
durante el verano pasado si bien
recuerdo fue a través de una amiga ella
nos presentó nos presentó a baby
empezamos a hablar en un cafecito
si una amiga nos presentó y nos interesó
mucho las las amigas ryan nos interesó
mucho tener como el prospecto poder
trabajar con una revista no y me parece
que a baby le interesó mucho poder
trabajar y poder
y apuntar gracias hacia una comunidad
más joven una comunidad estudiantil
entonces eso fue lo que primero nos
trajo juntos
el primer encuentro que tuvimos con el
concepto del evento fue en el evento 31
al evento 2 perdón
el evento 2 que sucedió durante este
verano baby nos invitó y fue un concepto
que la verdad me gustó mucho porque
justamente como en la asociación
estudiantil des lasa buscamos a unir a
la comunidad estudiantil de toda la zona
de montreal me pareció excelente el
proyecto de reunir también de un punto
de vista profesional a otros latinos de
esta área
vos estás muy metido en todo lo que es
la comunidad de líderes de negocio en
quebec
hay una cierta evolución que se está
dando aquí en montreal y en quebec de la
gente de negocios y sus relaciones tal
vez con otros organismos de negocios de
américa latina o está todo centrado sólo
aquí en quebec yo creo que sí la verdad
no tengo mucho mucha experiencia como tú
dices estoy estoy bastante nuevo usuario
con el proyecto hace cuatro años y hace
cuatro años no eras
preguntaba la misma pregunta de hecho no
tengo ni la menor idea pero hoy por hoy
con la poca experiencia que tengo siento
que si siento que hay más participación
yo me acuerdo hace cuatro años más o
menos cuando yo iba a eventos de cámaras
de comercio
los rodríguez lópez éramos uno o dos no
te dabas cuenta hoy por hoy vas y vas
reconociendo hasta latino axtel de
méxico hasta donde tal parte si se va
habiendo más y si alguna conexión con
las cámaras de comercio por ejemplo de
toronto o de alberta o de vancouver yo
yo sí yo sí yo he estado en contacto con
con la cámara comercio en alberta bueno
la cámara comercio latinoamericana en
alberta con toronto si también con la
cámara comercial latinoamericana y la
cámara comercio de perú en toronto hay
una conversación unas redes que se van
creando en canadá es más me fuera de
canadá no fuera de canadá
pues yo yo en lo personal sí teniendo
conversaciones con camino de comercio de
boston porque estábamos hablando de un
proyecto un nuevo proyecto de una
revista para empresarios que bueno en un
momento también tuvimos la ocasión de
hablar de eso estamos viendo si vamos a
sacar una revista a nivel canadiense con
estas ganas de comercio justamente y fue
porque tuve comunicación con ellos
hay un grupo miento de cámaras de
comercio peruanas si no estoy mal en
norteamérica estados unidos y canadá y
ellos bueno no sé cómo exactamente les
llegó la voz de este nuevo proyecto y me
contactaron pues porque están tales
interesados en que hagamos algo canadá
eeuu no hay nada concreto pero bueno por
supuesto están escuchando una de las
américas que hace un programa de radio
canadá internacional y estamos hoy con
nuestros invitados juan carlos quintana
iván gonzález ya integramos ibavi
rodríguez
todos ellos se están trabajando en un
evento que se llama el evento número 4
ahora cómo han desarrollado esas
alianzas con otros organismos que nos
apoyan
pues mira creo que
siempre mi carta siempre ha sido la más
importante es el trabajo en la primera
entrevista que tuvimos con leonora yo le
decía esto es lo que quiero con el
evento este es el concepto pero no había
nada todavía concreto no y a través de
las diferentes ediciones pues nos dimos
cuenta que era lo que estábamos
presentando al principio no había muchos
comunitarios no habían muchos cámaras
que puedan confiar en nosotros pero para
este evento 4 por ejemplo tenemos la
dicha de contar con de shanghai que es
una gran institución financiera en
quebec que sé que está basada en
principios del cooperativismo correcto
tenemos la cooperativa también en su
cuenta nacional que es un organismo no
gubernamental de cooperación
internacional de la parte y quebequense
porque tenía incluso de la parte con él
ese curso estuvo en la edición pasada la
edición número 3 su hijo es en esta
edición número 4 también tenemos a phil
acción es un organismo gubernamental que
bien brinda fondos para las pequeñas
empresas sobre todo a la comunidad pero
sobre todo a la comunidad
en inmigrantes
también tenemos al link talent que es
una agencia también de reclutamiento
para las mujeres para las líderes
femeninas justamente la mesa se ve muy
viril como invitados hay mujeres
participando en esto en este tipo de en
el evento y la organización atrás de
cada hombre siempre hay una gran mujer y
estoy completamente mira en mi equipo
por lo menos en agenda social yo somos
33 socios
suelo el hombre son son dos mujeres que
me empujan a salir a la cámara y ahora
este el cuarto evento se va a llevar a
cabo el 22 de febrero en esta dirección
es en máquina
juan carlos quintana que es un viejo
conocido nuestro no es viejo de edad
sino viejo conocido nuestro que además
fue periodista en radio canadá
internacional
eso es el que va a animar esta esta
noche esta fiesta puede decir que es lo
que nos que es lo que la gente va a
esperar a encontrar en el evento 4 pues
la oportunidad de crear lazos
profesionales como dije antes o por qué
hay tipo de todo tipo de invitados hay
todo tipo de industrias que van a estar
presentes
el objetivo es verdaderamente crear una
red de contactos todos se mueven una red
de contactos y poder contar con la
presencia de varias de varias industrias
nos permite pues que cada uno de los
participantes pueda sacarle provecho a
esta a este encuentro lo que yo
encuentro interesante desde el relevo
que tomo baby y agenda social con esto
es que vino a ser un complemento a lo
que estaba haciendo la cámara de
comercio latinoamericana de quebec en
una época
los cócteles de red de contactos y pues
combinando con la comida la de los
contactos y la música han hecho que esta
fiesta que no hay que asumir se ayuna
hay un concepto que está de por medio y
es el 'speed dating' que es la que es el
la cita de los el encuentro de los que
es básicamente en su principio era una
forma para que hombres y mujeres se
conozcan en
un lugar específico con una brevísima
entrevista de 5 minutos
y una entrevista de trabajo
de trabajo de pareja
que es otro tipo de trabajo también pero
cómo va a funcionar esto el 'speed
dating' de compañías como como como la
vez es decir si yo soy de una compañía
voy a ya que como funciona bien con que
me encuentro de llegar al principio
vamos a tener un
un cóctel donde todos van a estar
hablando pero en la idea el por qué se
hizo esto el concepto fue porque hay
personas
personalmente como yo que somos muy
tímidas al hablar cuando no conoces
alguien cuando conoces a alguien es
facilísimo pero cuando no conoces entrar
en un círculo de un grupo de personas
que ya está hablando es difícil entonces
esta forma
es simplemente para ayudar a esas
personas a que se puedan conocer y si de
esas 5 o 10 personas que van a conocer
en este business 'speed dating' tales te
interesa alguien pues listo cuando
regresemos al cóctel vamos a poder
hablar pero ya se rompió el hielo pizza
es que no es bueno es un poco frío
es una idea un concepto que queremos
innovar un poco cuando se rompe el hielo
hay que preparar los vasos
justamente uno de los rasgos de la
comunidad latinoamericana al igual que
muchas otras comunidades inmigrantes es
que en comparación con la población
que lleva generaciones en esta en esta
parte de las américas tienen un nivel
más elevado de desempleo
esta réflex esta esta realidad hace
parte de vuestro trabajo lo incorporan a
su a su forma de tomar la iniciativa
no necesariamente te diré la verdad que
no es para como primera primera idea no
puede ser que si al salgado oportunidad
de trabajo si los asilo hay enhorabuena
pero no no necesariamente fue la idea
principal creo que era más que todo red
de contactos entre empresarios entre
profesionales y ahora con estudiantes
por supuesto que sí yo personalmente una
de mis misiones en estas reuniones o con
mi papel en la cámara comercio era
básicamente de facilitar los contactos
que yo he logrado hacer porque ya tengo
varios inviernos de estar aquí en canadá
gente y tuve la dicha de estudiar aquí y
hacer mi red de contactos profesiones en
canadá
entonces facilitarle a la gente que
estaba buscando una oportunidad alguien
que es ingeniero yo conozco a una a un
bufete de ingenieros o alguien que es
arquitecto yo conozco a otro arquitecto
el objetivo es de facilitar la red de
contacto que logrado tener en estos
últimos años para beneficio de la gente
que está llegando y que todavía no se ha
integrado
laboral es un problema que tenemos a mí
me parece que si le estuvieran américa
latina' me interesaría saber cuál es la
fortaleza de los latinoamericanos
latinas y latinoamericanos gente de
negocios que están instalados aquí en
quebec en que se destacan en qué rubros
creo que creo que si no me equivoco de
la cámara comercio latinoamericana y
creo que trata de eso no estoy estoy al
tanto y no quiero decir algo que no que
desconozco pero creo que ellos han hecho
un estudio a nivel
pero simplemente con la gente que asiste
al evento y que son gente de negocios es
que ustedes pueden decir cuál es el tipo
de negocios y gracias a sus eventos yo
he llegado a conocer a académicos a
gente que trabaja en industrias hasta en
la minería gente que está en
comunicaciones realmente es diverso
super nivel ver sobre lo que hace que
estos networking cocktails sean una gran
oportunidad para todas las personas que
asisten de simplemente de diversificar
la manera en la que piensan sage y al
encontrarte a un profesional que esté en
un área que tú nunca hubieras pensado
que tú pudo haber ayudado al hacer el
link se crean nuevas ideas y nuevos
proyectos que pueden surgir de ahí lo
cual brinda oportunidades más allá de lo
que podamos imaginar no tenemos si
también la porque a veces en américa
latina no tenemos todas las herramientas
necesarias a veces para hacer un trabajo
no tiene que arreglarse las
instrucciones de que ser creativo y los
latinos creo que traen mucha de esa
creatividad a las industrias aquí
canadienses porque hay que hacerse los
kitos no hay que arreglárselas
que ingeniárselas aporta mucha
diversidad acá hay un mensaje en
facebook de javier gonzález que siempre
está con nosotros javier gonzález un
saludo javier gusto verte y javier dice
que cara hay ahora que me di tiempo para
verlos en vivo está fallando mi facebook
qué lástima de todos modos saludos a
todos en el castor cibernético desde
guadalajara méjico un compatriota
ahora ustedes son estudiantes de la
universidad mcgill que está estudiando
por curiosidad negocios comercio en
medicina bastante sociología no yo estoy
haciendo un doctorado en matemáticas
caramba sí cuántos años tienes perdón 23
23 años ya estás en un doctorado los
estudiantes
hice una licenciatura en física hice una
maestría en matemáticas en méxico no
aquí yo desde acabando los estudios
secundarios me vine aquí para la
universidad directamente
si yo estudio educación en educación
somos amigos desde que tenemos 11 años
una vieja amiga nos conocimos en la
escuela la escuela hicieron que el
colegio franco-mexicana en el colegio
franco mexicano pues también que era una
oportunidad única para nosotros porque
mientras nos quedamos en en américa a 5
horas en avión de nuestra casa podríamos
compartir la cultura francesa y
norteamericana entonces
en especial en temas de educativos se me
hacía muy interesante ver esta fusión
entre dos dos maneras de pensar y de
educar a las personas
y es aquí en que lo concebimos un poco
como una aventura cuando a los 18 años
que nos vinimos para aquí fue teníamos
ese lado de querer conservar el francés
siempre hemos tenido el lado francés en
nuestra vida y no necesariamente
queríamos ir a franquiciar porque estaba
muy lejos de latinoamérica entonces
todos saben ya lo que está pasando en
eeuu claro y un reciente informe decía
que las universidades canadienses
incluyendo a maggie les están
registrando un mayor número de
estudiantes que vienen que dejan la
opción de eeuu debido al clima reinante
ya para escoger que nada en el estudio
entre los latinoamericanos entre los
estudiantes que ustedes ven se puede
venir si ustedes mira
no puedo considerar a un experto en el
tema pero si escuchado rumores sobre
esto no y en efecto desde aparecer
este este semestre escolar se registró
una enorme tasa de registros de
estudiantes estadounidenses
no sé la verdad que se deba posiblemente
porque pagan menos colegiatura en gran
parte a la política implementada porque
porque ya la universidad de ottawa lanzó
un comunicado y no sólo pago a la
universidad de alberta y lo hizo lo está
haciendo magill y concordia decir han
decidido han ya el mensaje está lanzado
a abrir las puertas a los estudiantes
expulsados de estados unidos entonces
hubo un caso me acuerdo lo leí de
comentaban de la universidad de ottawa
él es un es un joven que está haciendo
un doctorado en la universidad de ottawa
y es de uno de los seis países
musulmanes con cuya entrada está
prohibida en eeuu está casado y su
esposa está haciendo un doctorado en
eeuu resulta que ahora él no puede ir a
verla eeuu ni ella venir para caminar
entonces él hizo un pedido concreto a la
universidad de ottawa para que permitan
que su esposa venga a ser su doctorado a
la universidad o thiago con servicio
facilitado entonces se están dando
muchos de estos casos y creo que se van
a dar muchos más no sé por ejemplo
ahorita lo que está diciendo de muchos
estudios
americanos que han entrado
nueva ingresa que la universidad muchos
de ellos son
hijos de inmigrantes y sed yo creo que
debe de haber algo que tiene que ver con
la nueva política de donald trump pero
de todas formas cuando llegas aquí a la
universidad en canadá hay políticas
activas hechas por la universidad de
aceptación de lo que llaman 66 en los
que están seguros para ser seguros en
los que todos los miembros de la
comunidad de la universidad toman
precaución en intentar de ser
incluyentes y si se siente lo sientes en
las personas y cómo se relacionan y y
una universidad como bayer que es
extremadamente internacional y se han
visto enriquecida por tener estas
políticas más incluyentes que te
permiten interactuar con estudiantes de
todo el mundo con personas con culturas
completamente diferentes que simplemente
vienen a enriquecer el país y la
diversidad pablo quería agregar
justamente al respecto a este tema de
que quizá ahora de ahora en adelante
haya muchísimo más estudiantes que
vengan justamente aquí a montreal porque
montreal se acaba de clasificar como la
mejor ciudad universitaria del mundo
dice que salió ayer en el instituto
quacquarelli symonds quien en su quinta
edición ellos hace una recopilación de
las 100 mejores ciudades en el mundo y
muy coronó a montreal como la mejor la
ciudad universitaria
la que interesa más a los estudiantes
porque este año en este estudio que
hicieron participaron también los
estudiantes y entre todos escogieron a
montreal entonces simplemente para
agregar esa nota de que además de trump
está que la ciudad misma sobresale no en
lo que respecta a estudios
universitarios si definitivamente en
montreal es un paraíso estudiantil
habiendo una cantidad de estudiantes
aquí se queda una muy buena dinámica y
eso
hablo se les había preguntado a los
estudiantes que votaron también porque
elegían montreal y las dos los dos temas
que sobresalían eran de que es una
ciudad multicultural
donde hay hay una convivencia que es muy
pacífica entre cualquier cantidad de
gente que vino de países tan diversos en
primero y segundo el bilingüismo la
gente viene por el bilingüismo de
montreal entonces es una ciudad que da
muchas oportunidades a los estudiantes
extranjeros es cierto que en el fondo es
un trilingüismo para todos nosotros pero
ahora volviendo al evento el evento
número 4
y qué es lo que funciona vendiendo
billetes ahí como que campaña como están
difundiendo la el evento el evento tiene
un costo de 15 dólares para los
estudiantes 30 para profesionales y
empresarios y ex estudiantes
el primero en enero creo que sacamos
también una campaña de river
esa opción de latino si desde comprarlo
a un precio reducido gracias y ahorita
ya esta empresa regular
y ahora la existencia es
multigeneracional es solamente jóvenes
no te digo que es muy variada como como
dicen ellos creo que no solo en
profesiones en sectores sino también en
edades ya no es dirigido a un público
joven directamente no es un público
tampoco muy adulto sino es una mezcla
sabes es para todos los hispanos que
quieran hacer red de contactos ahora
pensemos una empresa por ejemplo como
belo una empresa grande y qué es lo que
ganaría asistiendo a este evento
creo que si quieres conocer quienes
están liderando la comunidad latina si
te quieres acercar a la comunidad latina
creo que están los están los líderes los
profesionales las empresas una
publicidad yo soy de las personas que
creo que una publicidad tiene que ser
dirigida hacia tu público
una publicidad de un carro en europa van
a hablar de la seguridad en eeuu van a
hablar del motor
entonces si tú quieres acercarte a ese
público no es una publicidad en general
tienes que ir a ver cuál es el público
qué es lo que están buscando pues creo
que es una buena forma de conocer
también al público ya que estamos
creciendo como comunidad aquí en
encontrar ahora hay decir este tipo de
eventos también se llaman eventos
similares en toronto en vancouver se ha
podido asistir a algunos de ellos ver
quiero y en eso cuál es la especificidad
de montreal
he asistido a uno en toronto la verdad
no he tenido la oportunidad tienen otros
en montreal si existen otros de otros
medios de comunicación también aquí en
montreal que están haciendo eventos
muy parecidos nosotros pero con otra
finalidad
perdón tu pregunta fue empieza es la
respuesta claro que que es lo específico
de montreal en comparación por ejemplo
lo que viste en toronto
creo que diversificó diversificación a
la diversidad gracias la diversidad de
las de las personas en toronto
vi mucho muchos sectores pero no no tan
diversificado como quién montreal esos
en lo personal eso fue lo que contás
como pudiste constatamos tantas gracias
nervioso
no te preocupes javier gonzález desde
guadalajara méjico
él dice felicitaciones a todos en la
mesa y asimismo por el día mundial de la
radio sigan trabajando como hasta ahora
muchísimas gracias
bien pues entonces este programa de los
fines de semana se dedica a los oyentes
así que vamos a damos lectura a las
cartas y también sugerimos algunos temas
para que nuestros oyentes puedan
justamente acudir a nuestro sitio y ver
qué es lo que tenemos esperando les
pablo qué es lo que tú tienes para
sugerir esta semana
rufo como tú sabes comenzó el 9 de
febrero y hasta este domingo 19 de
febrero de febrero la feria
internacional del libro de la habana y
en autores de creces que están
participando canalda es el invitado de
honor
la feria de del libro de la habana y con
ese efecto la oficina nacional de cine
de canadá firmó un acuerdo con la
televisora estatal cubana para
transmitir de nueve películas
canadienses durante el festival pero
además va a haber otras once películas
que se presentarán en el festival hay
salas de cine que están preparadas al
efecto para que la gente pueda ver el
cine canadiense y es la primera vez es
una primicia por decirlo así que es la
oficina nacional de cine de canadá firme
este tipo de acuerdo con cuba ya se ha
hecho con otros países pero con cuba es
el primero y bueno entonces durante el
acuerdo como tal les permite a la radio
a la televisora estatal cubana
transmitir nueve películas pero en el
marco del festival se van a presentar 20
películas
y tú le dará
ustedes saben cuál es la otra especie
que modifica el medio ambiente a parte
del ser humano cuál es el animal hay uno
solo en que modifica el elefante el
medio ambiente juan carlos que derrumba
árboles
el castor es el único que modifica el
medio ambiente construyendo casas
subterráneas de ahí bendigo abajo del
agua pues bien hay un equipo de toronto
de que es el profesor stephen server de
la universidad de toronto que se
especializan es un director del centro
de genómica aplicada y junto con otros
investigadores han secuenciado el genoma
por primera vez del castor y
completamente lo han hecho el castor en
cuestión se llama word es un inquilino
del zoológico de toronto y tiene 10 años
atrás como el tema es un poquito
complicado no me quiero equivocar
lo que han hecho es han utilizado un
nuevo método para secuenciar el genoma
que se llama justamente novo secuencia
de novo y lo que han hecho es utilizando
máquinas de última de último desarrollo
generación máquinas de secuenciación del
genoma que generó como generaron tres
mil millones de cartas químicas de
información que componen el genoma del
castor lo que es único en el proyecto es
que dice tuvimos que desarrollar algunos
nuevos métodos para unir realmente todas
estas 3.000 millones de cartas químicas
de información en un rompecabezas
completo porque no hicieron con el
castor en realidad este médico y su
equipo de genoma en toronto se
especializan en el autismo entonces él
explicaba que hay familias que tienen un
hijo autista otro no no conocen todavía
el porqué cuál es la causa saben que es
genético pero no saben por qué entonces
ellos dicen que lo que hicieron con el
genoma del castor que se parece mucho al
nuestro lo secuenciaron a partir de ser
es decir fue una cosa totalmente nueva y
que eso dicen ellos les va a permitir
avanzar en la investigación sobre el
autismo en los seres humanos entonces el
que hay que ir y entra el que quiera
entrar y escuchar el reportaje o leerlo
un poco va a tener más información es el
castor cibernético claro y castor el
castor gaucho también el castor gaucho
hay mucho que justamente causó estragos
en el sur de la argentina claro eso fue
en la época de perón y eso fue un primer
ministro canadiense que tuvo la
brillante idea de ponerse de acuerdo con
perón
pero me hizo cas toreado a que castores
en el sur de argentina que es el mismo
clima de canadá salvo que haya no
existen los depredadores del castor
naturales como existe aquí en canadá
entonces hoy no hoy se esconden los
castores no saben nada pero si los y
quería saber si había una predisposición
genética del castor si le gusta el
hockey o no hay seguramente que le gusta
si es canadiense retrata
entonces recomiendo
un análisis que se ha hecho estas
semanas después del no se han visto en
internet este es el célebre ap/tom de
más pobres insua del japonés que lo
jaloneaban como un pelele
sí sí y también su pelea telefónica con
el primer ministro de australia
malcolm turnbull entonces se esperaba
ya centro fue muy hábil así que lo que
se destaca es justamente la manera y la
lectura que se hace del apretón de manos
con donald trump en que fue le quitó el
espacio para que lo halle acercándole
del hombro toda nada todo lenguaje de
movimientos así que a partir de esa
dices del lenguaje corporal básicamente
él lo que dice está esta lectura de este
análisis de la visita de jazz incluido
su primera visita con a washington de
donde bajó de donald trump es que fue un
éxito para para los que nadie para que
nada
justamente lograr que finalmente pues
donald trump no ande diciendo cosas
estrambóticas y lo crucial y esto es
quizá hablaba justamente con gente en
méxico sobre el tratado de vil comercio
y claro que nada lo que le interesaba de
esa reunión era asegurarse hasta qué
punto el tratado de comercio iba a ser
afectado entonces lo que dice
trump usan una palabra que en inglés es
pero que en español podría ser cambiar
un poquito nada más
grandes cambios y en méxico justamente
hablaba con un profesor de un avanzada
área y decía que justamente la sensación
que tiene méxico en esta en esta
situación es que méxico se siente
abandonado y que son solamente eeuu y
canadá que se van a arreglar y pues
ya no son los tres amigos no sin así que
y tiene razón de sentirse abandonado
rojo porque es oficial ya autoridades
canadienses declararon que en comercio
no hay amigos y que canadá le interesa
reforzar sus vínculos económicos con
eeuu y bueno peces y méxico pues sale
perdiendo en este paseo pues pobre
méxico una vez más
bueno entonces digamos que es esa los
temas que le recomendamos a ustedes
limón ya tengo ni idea nuestros amigos
en facebook y creo que con esto llegamos
básicamente al final del programa son
las dos de la tarde estamos en estudio
30 de radical internacional estaremos en
el evento
22 en la gran zona
claro entonces nos veremos allá pero por
su pasado que no se pueden perder claro
que no tiene entonces muchas gracias
estuvieron hoy con ustedes en el estudio
diga no era chapman pablo gómez barrios
y les habla roja valencia y nuestros
invitados
muchas gracias con carlos quintana
javier rodríguez iván gonzález y soy y
también nuestro compañero de trabajo
leonardo si menos que está justamente
haciendo posible estas estas imágenes y
también a nuestro nuestro técnico detrás
de las de la única de las pantallas de
la gran ventana dominique mercy entonces
eso es todo cuídense mucho estaremos
juntos fachadas
hasta la próxima semana dios muchas
gracias muchas gracias